on this monday night fear and
desperation in afghanistan
risking everything to escape the taliban
the chaos at kabul's airport prime
minister please sir help this is the
right time to do something and the
pressure on canada to rescue more
afghans who helped us and the message
from the american president about the
catastrophic exit the buck stops with me
the conservative plan for canada's
pandemic recovery we need to help people
as we secure the future from a million
jobs to 50 percent off at restaurants
the tories lay their election platform
on the table
plus the infernos shutting down highways
in bc forcing thousands from their homes
and the rush to rescue before a powerful
storm strikes the urgent search for
survivors of the haiti earthquake
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
the first time you watch this you think
it can't be real afghans so desperate to
escape taliban rule they cling to the
outside of a u.s military plane as it
attempts to take off but this is really
how america's longest war is ending in
disaster as the plane soars up bodies
appear to fall to the ground we've
chosen to pause the video there and not
show that there are reports at least
seven people have died it's not clear
how and that u.s troops fired into the
air trying to clear the tarmac more u.s
troops have been deployed american
military dogs and their handlers were
able to quietly get out but there are so
many afghan people and such chaos at the
airport it is unlikely everyone who
wants to leave will be able to though
late today came reports american
evacuation flights are taking off again
good evening and thanks for joining us
prime minister justin trudeau who has
promised to bring 20 thousand afghan
citizens to canada says some have
already arrived
at least 807 afghans have been evacuated
to date and over 500 have already
arrived in canada
and late today the u.s president who
just last month said a taliban takeover
of afghanistan was not inevitable
addressed the nation joe biden admitted
the collapse happened faster than
expected but says he does not regret his
decision to withdraw
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves i know there are
concerns about why we did not begin
evacuating
afghans civilians sooner
part of the answer
that some of the afghans did not want to
leave earlier
still hopeful for their country
and part of it because the afghan
government
and its supporters discouraged us from
organizing the mass exodus to avoid
triggering as they said
a crisis of confidence
this was the first day of what the
taliban called the islamic emirate of
afghanistan the people including girls
and women are again at the mercy of the
taliban's draconian version of islamic
law
eric sorensen begins our coverage
tonight in a warning some of the images
are disturbing the scene of utter chaos
at the cabell airport is just a glimpse
of the confusion and fear that is unseen
throughout this country of 37 million in
kabul afghans on target lists are
reportedly being rounded up by the
taliban there are fleeting images of
bodies in the streets as if in a family
portrait taliban leaders all men posed
in the presidential palace
this commander offered assurances
afghans need not worry that mujahideen
have entered the city
the taliban are even employing men on
the street interviews to calm citizens
it's very peaceful says this man there
isn't any danger here
but the mayhem on unofficial video and
the fear and the voices of afghan women
tell a different story i have never
never
failed it to this extent helpless
thousands are seeking help from canada
this student whose identity we are
concealing to protect her worked to
promote women's rights now she is in
hiding and her relatives in brampton
ontario are worried sick she said they
they have to hide in the basement
and the taliban is going house to house
and recruiting every young man the prime
minister is promising more help from
this country we are working very closely
with the us the uk and other allies uh
to establish uh ways in which we are
going to be able to get more and more
people out of afghanistan for 20 years
afghanistan modernized now images of
women are being whitewashed progress
wiped out in a matter of days at the
united nations afghanistan's ambassador
deplored what is happening i'm speaking
for millions of household girls and
women
who are about to lose their freedom but
he no longer speaks for the people in
power in afghanistan members of the u.n
security council vowed to pressure the
taliban to respect human rights the
world is watching
we cannot and must not abandon the
people of afghanistan the u.s president
is not apologizing for withdrawing
american troops but was surprised the
regime so quickly abandoned the fight
against the taliban this did unfold more
quickly than we had anticipated the
afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight the reality on the
ground now thousands of frightened
afghans are trying to leave the country
and the international community
including canada have been caught
unprepared eric sorenson global news
that it's come to this that the u.s and
its allies did not anticipate how easily
the taliban would take over and did not
facilitate getting people out of the
country sooner is widely considered a
failure the canadian government has
promised for weeks to get interpreters
and other contractors who work for
canada out of the country prime minister
justin trudeau has committed to
resettling thousands of them and other
at-risk afghans he says 500 have arrived
in canada now canadian officials tell
global news it is ready to resume
evacuation flights once the u.s gives
them clearance our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson is traveling with
the liberal leader on the second day of
the campaign
a desperate appeal to justin trudeau
from a former afghan interpreter for the
canadian special operations forces the
prime minister please sir help this is
the right time to do something i
i am so
emotional right now
i could not express the feelings of
these people to you
the situation on the ground is dire as
the taliban hunts former interpreters
thousands of them told to drop
everything and travel to kabul for
extraction to canada but then the
embassy shut down and flights stopped
these photos show former interpreters
and their families exposed and
vulnerable with the situation worsening
and they didn't have any information and
they were panicking they were pushing
each another and
i could not describe when the people
left the place they were telling me we
were shamed
that we served the canadian forces what
they have done with us the prime
minister had been criticized for
promising help with no specifics or
timeline on monday that changed mr
trudeau said canadian troops and
military aircraft are on standby in
kuwait and will fly into kabul as soon
as the airfield is secure absolutely if
we can see
the
airfield properly secured we will be
there alongside our partners to help
evacuate afghans but as i said the
situation right now is extremely fluid
extremely difficult
mere hours after trudeau's announcement
the americans retook control of the
airfield with the help of afghan special
forces from kandahar global news has
learned canadian flights and special
forces are ready to resume evacuation
flights as soon as the americans grant
them clearance to land my interpreter
the
calman it's too little too late she's
angry with prime minister for calling an
election this is not a time for shaking
hands and kissing babies this is a time
for rescuing babies afghanistan has
dominated the election for justin
trudeau as images of desperation and
tragedy pour out of kabul for some it is
a reminder of the 2015 election when the
image of a drowned tiny syrian refugee
boy alan kurdi caught the attention and
anger of canadians leading then liberal
leader justin trudeau to promise to take
more than 40 000 syrian refugees getting
those canadian military evacuation
flights back in the air and on their way
to kabul a political priority for the
government according to a security
source who has direct knowledge of the
situation it has been a flash point on
mr trudeau's campaign
and while there's hope ahead for the
canadians interpreters and gurkhas left
on the ground the taliban still has a
kill list for anybody who worked for
coalition forces and the challenge will
be getting them to the airport safely
while campaigning in quebec today justin
trudeau outlined his party's vision for
canada's economic recovery if reelected
his liberal party would extend the
canada recovery hiring program until
march 31st of 2022 it would also provide
the tourism industry with temporary wage
and rent support of up to 75 percent of
their expenses to help get them through
the winter
the conservatives also focused heavily
on the economy today tory leader aaron
o'toole released his party's plan for
economic recovery it includes promises
to incentivize job creation stimulate
the economy build homes and help parents
pay for child care abigail beeman
reports on the tory commitments and the
possible long-term implications
my wife loves the picture
erin o'toole hopes canadians love this
too not just the men's health magazine
style cover but the contents we will
secure jobs by recovering the one
million jobs lost during the pandemic
and more in one year
some of the economic promises include a
job surge plan covering up to 50 percent
of the salary of new hires for six
months loans up to two hundred thousand
dollars for small and medium-sized
businesses in hard-hit sectors with up
to 25 forgiven i think that's uh
indicative of the seriousness in which
the you know the situation our
industry's in right now there are
several boutique items a month-long
holiday to waive the gst at retail
stores this fall dine and discover 50
off at restaurants monday to wednesday
for a month and 200 a month for families
who take care of parents over age 70.
there's more money for health care
through boosted provincial transfers and
a focus on mental health your platform
promises the most spending and
investment right up front and then also
to balance the budget in 10 years can
you guarantee that after those first few
years there won't be cuts coming to
canadians we need to help people as we
secure the future and our plan to
balance the budget over the course of 10
years by the decade is fair not exactly
a guarantee by providing a longer
timeline uh that's a great
balance for the common refrain that
people would have that conservatives are
going to slash and burn the only way to
balance a budget and have permanent
spending increases is to increase your
tax take so that's either going to mean
higher rates fewer deductions or some
combination of the two then there's
child care the liberals have been
touting their popular 10 a day plan
conservatives would scrap it in favor of
a tax credit up to 75 percent for
low-income families it looks a lot like
the harper plan from 15 years ago
which is great in terms of reducing
costs even though it won't reduce costs
quite as much as the liberal plan
promised to do for
especially the expensive provinces like
ontario
but what's really important is it does
nothing for demand one more thing i'll
highlight in these
160 pages a national rapid test program
plus at the borders o'tool would see
anyone entering canada take a rapid test
and possibly a pcr test too regardless
of vaccination status but none of the
promises in here are costed that will
come later in the campaign donna all
right abigail beeman thanks ndp leader
jagmeet singh was in toronto he is
promising to claw back emergency
pandemic benefits paid to corporations
that hiked executive pay while receiving
federal support
we're the only ones in this election
that have the courage to say
instead of putting the burden on people
instead of putting the burden on workers
we're going to ask the alteration to pay
their fair share starting with making
sure companies that took public money
and abused that are reimbursing that are
paying back that money that they took
and green party leader anime paul was
also in toronto today her focus was the
climate crisis unfolding in canada paul
pointed to the fires raging in parts of
this country and rising sea levels and
says the only way to stop things from
getting worse is to take drastic action
now paul says the greens are the only
party to oppose new pipeline projects
oil and gas exploration and fracking
fierce wildfires explode coming up
towering flames in b.c forced more
people to flee
in b.c forest fires are raging again
people in the interior say it looks
apocalyptic high winds and high
temperatures have made everything worse
close to 5 000 people have been ordered
to evacuate and multiple structures have
been destroyed and though cooler weather
is now moving in the situation is still
extremely volatile robin gill reports
the blue sky over merit bc has been
obscured by shades of red and black the
flames and smoke of a monster fire more
than sixty thousand hectares in size and
growing is now threatening the city of
seven thousand people
jacqueline newman and her family left
nearby logan lake she fled to one of the
many evacuation centers that had been
set up in safer spots of british
columbia the black thick smoke since
about noon yesterday it looked like it
was eight o'clock at night
a different fire has spilled over onto
the coquihalla highway a major connector
between vancouver and the interior
that's now been shut down the coca-cola
is referred to as the highway through
hill and that's exactly what it was last
night dawn adamson managed to get
through before the highway closed she
thought the fire was far enough away as
i'm driving through it
it's actually right beside me
to the extent that it's well i could
feel it in west kelowna another fire
forced a neighborhood to be evacuated
there are reports of homes being damaged
we are actively fighting fires in the
backyards of homes
on a number of streets 50 homes may have
been destroyed in a beach community
close to kelowna kalini beach looks in
really bad shape doesn't look like
anything survived there making matters
worse 10 people refused to leave and
firefighters had to rescue them
detracting from the bigger challenge of
the fires the fire activity we've seen
this summer the fire conditions they've
been extreme
in these conditions escape routes can
quickly be compromised or cut off
completely
there's some relief with the rain and
cooler temperatures but it's going to
take a lot more precipitation to make
these fires go away it will really take
that significant amount of rainfall
which you probably won't see until the
fall fall is weeks away it's still
august still summer
the newmans are staying with friends for
now take it day by day and see how it
goes because that's all they can do in a
province where summer has been ruined by
an all too familiar fire season robin
gill global news chilliwack bc
the roadblocks to relief efforts in
haiti's earthquake zone next the
pandemic political turmoil and a
powerful storm complicate efforts to
save lives
more wild weather is not what haiti
needs right now after that powerful
earthquake the devastated part of the
caribbean island on saturday almost 1300
people are known to have died and that
number is expected to rise eleven years
ago a massive quake killed more than two
hundred thousand haitians displacing
thousands more crushing homes
infrastructure and the country's economy
haiti has never fully recovered from
that disaster making the situation now
even more dire here's mike drewlay
for all the loss and destruction
haitians were able to celebrate a brief
win
a woman pulled from the rubble dazed and
confused but alive moments later her son
was pulled to safety
saturday's 7.2 magnitude quake left the
poorest country in the western
hemisphere once again scrambling to
stand on its own those on the ground say
the area most affected around the town
of lakai is operating leaderless very
little government
presence police or central government
activity it's close to close to zero the
hospitals in the disaster zone were
overwhelmed with covet 19 cases before
the quake and to make matters worse
tropical depression grace is expected to
dump 100 millimeters of rain on the
thousands of haitians left homeless in
the streets which could accelerate the
spread of waterborne diseases
aid is on its way but nothing is easy in
haiti
the problem is that in between this area
and for the prince there's there's a lot
of
very well armed uh gangs uh uh you know
controlling the area so it's impossible
to get there
uh with the ground transportations
international organizations like world
vision have had to create a so-called
air bridge it's slow but safe
the needs are so
enormous so great that it's impossible
to
face the situation like it is now aid
organizations run by haitians in canada
are mobilizing their assets but even
they are hitting roadblocks in part
because of political turmoil after last
month's assassination of haiti's
president it's explosive
situation
haiti can't seem to catch a break
mike turley global news toronto
up next voting during a pandemic
vaccinations are mandatory for federal
workers but not for all the people
working and volunteering at the polls
safety is top of mind as canada prepares
for a federal election all employees in
the federal public service have been
told vaccination against covet 19 is
mandatory it is for employees in the
federally regulated air rail and marine
transportation sectors too but global
news has learned elections canada will
not mandate volunteers and staff working
at polling stations be vaccinated as
jamie morocco reports there's worry it's
a decision that may drive up
transmission
sue phillips wants to work at a calgary
polling station this election even
though it means she will come into
contact with hundreds of people during
the pandemic's fourth wave i feel
quite safe because i've been vaccinated
the 62 year old says she figured a
double dose would be mandatory to
volunteer but in an email to global news
elections canada says vaccination will
not be a requirement for election
workers while it will prioritize fully
vaccinated election officers to serve
vulnerable populations such as those
living in long-term care facilities or
first nations communities the agency
plans to instead focus on masking
sanitizing and physical distancing one
of the greatest groups that is going to
be coming into contact with millions and
millions of canadian voters are going to
be those who are working and
volunteering at our front line polling
stations dr samir sinha says given the
recent decision by the federal
government to mandate a full course of
covet 19 shots for all public servants
elections canada should follow suit
people should be vaccinated in order to
work in these polling centers or to
volunteer but political science
professor nelson wiseman says this could
shrink an already small volunteer pool
elections canada needs poll workers
that's going to be their main challenge
in newfoundland and labrador's spring
election a surge in coveted cases caused
so many officers to back out on election
day the province was left scrambling for
volunteers and in nova scotia officials
had to put out a call for more poll
workers ahead of tuesday's vote justin
trudeau could have required
that people working in polling stations
be
vaccinated he has not done that and
while seemingly provincial polls have
gone ahead safely phillips hopes
elections canada will rethink its policy
it's just not right that they should
have to be in front of someone who
hasn't been vaccinated determined to do
her part to protect workers voters and
the democratic process jamie morocco
global news toronto
that is global national for this monday
i'm donna friesen tonight sir canada is
st brew lake in saskatchewan thanks for
watching take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you